this is actually the most disgusting
thing I've ever seen the world of
mechanical keyboards is a vast one it
can be overwhelming confusing and most
importantly expensive but before you go
looking at keyboards it's crucial to
know what type of switches you'd like
first to start there are three main
types of switches linear tactile and
clicky linear switches give you almost
no physical feedback and are often very
silent providing a smooth and consistent
feeling
now with tactile switches there is a
bump in the actuation that gives the
user a noticeable feedback
finally there are clicky switches which
as the name suggests are well clicky
they offer the most physical sensation
and an even more audible clacking noise
we strongly recommend picking up a
switch sampler it's the best way to get
a feel for different switches and figure
out what thought suits you we're going
to suffocate the CCB because we're
trying to make this